[Music]
you are quite active in social media I
have a bunch of friends actually who who
are following you around all the time on
social media what you're up to and
you're kind of the king of the selfies
really you take some great selfies yes
and get them out there I want to know
how would you like a lesson a lesson in
how to take a selfie yeah yeah sure I
don't do are you good in it
no I'm terrible at it I'm not very the
first the first thing is you have to
take maybe thirty thousand pictures of
yourself which tonight before we get my
lesson then I show a couple of your
selfies right let's take a look at some
of your selfies this one is good I like
that that's you contemplating it's just
keep scrolling through that's yeah this
is you I like this guy that guy's a bat
at the airport oh that that's a Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay's spoils of
Babylon in miniseries very novellas
cameo they're very nice there you are
with a building Dallas Texas okay let's
keep moving that's the show I did a film
with Harmony Korine I love that
character is his name what the hell
what's happening yeah that was and I get
to bring more great directors terrence
malick i did a cameo and i cut my hair
off on stage there you know that's real
blood yeah real blood helps in a selfie
teach me how you take these good selfies
i don't know what what to do so you just
okay hold on us remain calm okay I'm is
that the moon
Andy can Andy photobomb us in the
background Andy do you mind just getting
in the just I think if it's a selfie
with us and Andy's creeping up
photobombing that's gonna add to the
excitement
let's see that that's terrific
[Applause]
in your ear you're coming you're coming
right out of Val Kilmer's ear